dans le centre de l'hémicycle et on a
compté ils sont déjà une trentaine de
ministres ministres délégués ou
secrétaire d'État donc encore une fois
cette séance cette semaine avec une
forte présence un fort taux de présence
du gouvernement dans l'hémicycle avec
cette semaine des moments forts que l'on
attend consacré à la pénurie de
carburant il y aura pas moins de deux
questions là-dessus mais la toute
première question dans quelques instants
dans quelques secondes sera posé par le
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
Patrick
et bien à la dégradation du et bien
comme ça du climat social en ce moment
c'est en tout cas l'argument des
socialistes et vous le savez lorsque
c'est un président de groupe politique
au Parlement qui pose une question
gouvernement c'est l'habitude au
Parlement c'est toujours le chef du
gouvernement qui répond donc Patrick
Kanner va poser sa question d'un instant
à l'autre et ce sera bien Elisabeth
borne la première ministre qui va lui
répondre sur cette donc question du de
la dégradation du climat social en tout
cas la thèse
socialiste on verra aussi les
conséquences de la hausse de l'énergie
c'est parti pour cette séance
[Musique]
pas reçu d'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
tu l'envoi poids il est donc adopté sous
les réserves d'usage madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues l'ordre du
jour appelle les questions d'actualité
au Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmis sur Public Sénat et sur notre
site internet chacun sera attentif à
observer
des principes qui sont des principes
cardinaux ici le respect il s'agit du
respect des uns ou des autres et respect
plus mathématique qui est celui du temps
de parole
je vais donner immédiatement la parole
au président Patrick canaire pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain vous avez la parole monsieur
le président
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre
nous nous sommes rencontrés pour la
première fois à votre demande de 27
juillet dernier et je vous avais fait
part de ma grande préoccupation sur la
situation sociale de la rentrée de
septembre et je vous avais proposé une
revalorisation significative du SMIC
mais surtout l'organisation d'une grande
conférence salariale pour anticiper les
difficultés financières prévisibles de
l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens
ma vie répondu que telle ne serait pas
votre choix
privilégiant la seule solution des
accords de branche
aujourd'hui le désordre s'installe la
colère gronde et les premières victimes
sont les salariés obligés de prendre
leur voiture la crise des carburants que
traverse notre pays et le premier étage
d'une crise sociale généralisée qui est
sur son pas de tir
les inégalités se creusent et ce n'est
qu'un début faire preuve d'autoritarisme
en réquisitionnant les salariés sans
responsabiliser les employeurs ne
permettra pas de revenir à une paix
sociale à laquelle nous aspirons aucune
prime même Macron limitée dans le temps
et dans l'espace ne remplacera une
revalorisation durable des salaires vous
anticipez plus vous ne faites plus que
pallier et mal par des rustines
extrêmement coûteuses pour la solidarité
nationale que vous convoquez pour mieux
exonérer les plus aisés de nos
concitoyens les pompes à essence
s'assent le pouvoir d'achat est siphonné
par l'inflation mais les dividendes eux
continuent à ruisseler madame la
Première ministre cette situation est
absurde certaines entreprises peuvent
tripler leur bénéfices profitant de la
crise actuelle mais sans augmenter leurs
salariés mais sans contribuer à l'effort
national ma question est donc simple
face à cette aberration allez-vous
choisir le camp de la résignation ou le
camp du combat pour la justice sociale
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre madame la
Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur
président canner alors je vous remercie
monsieur le Président pour vos propos
parfaitement équilibrés et modérée
s'agissant des profits exceptionnels
j'ai le plaisir de vous indiquer que
vous pourrez dans le cadre de l'examen
du projet de loi de finance examiner une
disposition qui doit permettre de taxer
les profits exceptionnels notamment des
compagnies pétrolières donc je n'ai pas
d'autres que vous aurez à cœur de voter
cette disposition
[Applaudissements]
et je vous précise également monsieur
président que moi aussi j'échange
régulièrement avec des salariés avec des
fonctionnaires avec les Français qui
travaillent et moi aussi je parle avec
les organisations syndicales et puis
j'ai changé également régulièrement avec
des chefs d'entreprise et tous me disent
la même chose les Français veulent vivre
de leur travail
cette conviction c'est de la mienne et
c'est aussi celle de mon gouvernement le
travail c'est la dignité c'est
l'émancipation et c'est bien pour
protéger le pouvoir d'achat des Français
que nous avons pris des mesures fortes
je pense notamment aux bouclier
tarifaire qui est la mesure la plus
protectrice d'Europe et depuis plus de 5
ans nous agissons pour que le travail
paye toujours mieux je pense notamment à
la suppression pour que le travail paye
toujours mieux je pense notamment à la
suppression de certaines cotisations
sociales ou à l'augmentation de la prime
d'activité et puis cet été nous avons
pris des mesures nous allons y venir
messieurs les sénateurs cet été nous
avons pris des mesures supplémentaires
en revalorisant la prime d'activité en
créant la prime de partage de la valeur
en facilitant le déblocage de l'épargne
salariale ces dispositifs ce sont les
salariés et les entreprises qui avancent
ensemble ce sont des salariés qui
bénéficient des richesses qu'il
contribuent à créer alors monsieur le
Président vous me parlez de salaire je
voudrais rappeler qu'en France au niveau
interprofessionnel nous avons le
dispositif le plus protecteur du salaire
minimum avec les hausses automatiques le
SMIC en un an a été revalorisé de 8% je
vous rappelle que l'inflation est de 6%,
sauf erreur de ma part 8% c'est plus que
6%
. l'inflation en France est de 6%
monsieur le sénateur naturellement
naturellement cette revalorisation
automatique du SMIC doit conduire les
branches professionnelles à revoir leur
grille salariale depuis le début de
l'année plus de 500 accords de branches
sur les salaires ont été signés il y en
avait eu que 418 sur toute l'année 2019
et je rappelle également que le
Parlement a voté cet été une disposition
qui accélère les négociations dans les
branches dans les minima sont inférieurs
au SMIC donc la dynamique elle est là
elle doit se prolonger car je suis
d'accord toutes les entreprises qui le
peuvent doivent augmenter les salaires à
fortiori dans la période d'inflation que
nous connaissons mais monsieur le
Président Kanner je sais que vous le
savez c'est du dialogue social que
viendra la réponse le dialogue social
j'y crois profondément mais le dialogue
social c'est se mettre autour de la
table c'est respecté les accords
majoritaires c'est chercher des
compromis ça n'est pas bloqué le pays
alors oui mon gouvernement croit au
dialogue social nous prenons nos
responsabilités pour que ce dialogue
social puisse se tenir et que les
résultats en soi respectés je vous
remercie monsieur le Président Keller
[Applaudissements]
très second madame ministre tout d'abord
vous savez bien que l'inflation pour les
ménages les plus modestes n'est pas de
6% elle est de 13 à 14% par rapport au
panier moyen de ces de ces ménages
premièrement deuxièmement vous me parlez
de dialogue social comment voulez-vous
faire comprendre les salariés de Total
qui demandent une valorisation de 10%,
7% pour l'inflation 3% pour les profils
d'entreprise que leur patron monsieur
pouyanet a augmenté de 52% son salaire
en 2021 pour atteindre 500.000 euros par
mois voilà ce qui est injuste et vous ne
le combattez pas vous êtes faible avec
l'effort et fort avec les faibles
merci
la parole est à notre collègue et rigole
pour le gros du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole mon chers collègues merci
à Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les Français vivent depuis
maintenant plus de 2 ans dans un
contexte particulièrement anxiogène
enchaînant crise sanitaire crise
économique guerre en Europe inflation
générale tout cela avec une capacité de
résilience remarquable qu'il est
important de souligner c'est expliquant
par les grèves des raffineries mais
aussi par une augmentation mal anticipée
de la consommation générée par les
remises à la pompe la pénurie de
carburant est venue donner le coup de
grâce à une partie de la population qui
ressent particulièrement la facture
sociale et territoriale
les Français qui n'ont aucun accès aux
transports en commun et non d'autres
moyens de locomotion que la voiture bien
sûr il a eu des comportements parfois
irresponsables de la part des usagers
qui se sont ruées sur les stocks
d'essence remplissant leur jerrican
après avoir rempli leur réservoir sans
doute les mêmes qui avaient à l'époque
épuisé les stocks de papier toilette de
farine ou de moutarde mais la réalité
est là et c'est avec cette réalité que
les toits doit composer les stations
services sont prises d'assaut les
Français font face à des difficultés
pour se déplacer des professionnels ne
peuvent plus travailler correctement y
compris dans les services essentiels à
la population
je sais que ce n'est pas au gouvernement
de discuter les salaires des grévistes
en tout cas il n'est pas l'acteur
principal de ses négociations mais il
est question ici de problèmes
d'approvisionnement sur un bien
stratégique qui pourrait potentiellement
paralyser jusqu'au service de santé et
de sécurité de notre pays
l'État a donc l'obligation de s'en mêler
après avoir mis en place quelques
mesures malheureusement insuffisantes
vous avez effectivement annoncé hier que
les préfectures pourraient
réquisitionner les salariés de certaines
raffineries en grève
pouvez-vous nous préciser comment cette
réquisition va se dérouler ne
craignez-vous pas que la justice vous
oppose la liberté fondamentale du droit
de grève comme cela a déjà été le cas en
2010 et si tel était le cas quelles
autres pistes envisagez-vous tout en
évitant d'apporter davantage de gasoil
russe pour répondre à la demande
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre déléguée en charge au nouveau
démocratique porte parole du
gouvernement monsieur Veyron
retour de micro mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur il
rigole merci pour votre merci pour votre
question vous l'avez dit le gouvernement
agit là où il peut et là où il doit agir
depuis le début de cette crise sociale
qui conduit à des situations de tension
réelle dans de nombreux départements
d'autres pays équipénalise des millions
de nos concitoyens pour aller au travail
pour aller faire leurs courses amener
leurs enfants à l'école parfois même
vous l'avez dit vous-même se soigner
nous avons d'abord suppléer au carburant
qui ne pouvait pas sortir des centres de
dépôt en apportant massivement et
notamment depuis la Belgique des
carburants à destination de la région
Hauts-de-France nous avons également
puisé dans nos réserves stratégiques de
carburant et démultiplier les camions
citerne il y a des norias organisés de
manière à pouvoir suppléer là aussi aux
difficultés rencontrées par de
nombreuses stations services nous avons
conscience que cela ne suffit pas à
régler le problème et ce que la première
ministre souhaite ardemment depuis le
premier jour c'est que le dialogue
social se fasse dans de bonnes
conditions qui l’aboutissent pour que
les blocages cessent or il y a deux cas
de figure il y a quatre figure du groupe
Epson notamment avec des centres de
dépôt de carburant situé en Normandie où
là la CFDT d'autres syndicats
réformistes ont signé avec leur
employeur un accord majoritaire cet
accord n'a pas été respecté ni soutenu
par la CGT qui a annoncé souhaité
continuer le blocage l'État prend alors
sa responsabilité en demandant au préfet
de prendre des arrêtés de réquisition
dans les plus brefs délais qui devraient
être opérationnels aujourd'hui de
manière à bloquer l'accès au dépôt de
carburant de port Jérôme et améliorer la
situation dans les jours qui viennent
dans l'autre cas de figure le groupe de
groupe Total a annoncé ouvrir les
négociations et les discussions sur les
salaires la CGT semble avoir décidé et
il faut on semble avoir décidé de
participer en tout cas au premier
réunion nous restons extrêmement
attentifs à l'évolution de ces
discussions et aux décisions d'arrêt du
blocage que nous appelons de nos vœux
sans quoi là aussi la première ministre
l'a annoncé l'état prendra ses
responsabilités et décidera position
nécessaire pour que chacun puisse
retrouver son quotidien dans des
conditions de normalité ça prendra
évidemment du temps plusieurs jours
chacun peut imaginer que le temps de
rouvrir des raffineries de pouvoir
extraire du carburant des dépôts mais la
situation s'améliorera de façon visible
dans les jours qui viennent je suis
la parole de notre collect Thomas dessus
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre dans un peu plus d'un mois
commencera la 22e Coupe du monde de
football au Qatar
sans préjugés de la sélection finale
cette année nous avons une équipe de
très haut niveau et cette coupe du monde
aurait dû être une très belle fête pour
la France pourtant on le voit il y a un
malaise qui monte pour ne pas dire du
dégoût y compris chez certains des plus
fervents supporters des Bleus en réalité
nous sommes face à un dilemme une
troisième étoile sur le maillot bleu
vaut-elle toutes les compromissions car
des compromissions il y en a eu et il y
en a encore en 2010 Kylian Mbappé
n'avait que 12 ans mais à cette époque
là Nicolas Sarkozy œuvrait déjà avec
succès pour que la monarchie Cathary se
voit attribuer l'organisation de
l'événement 12 ans plus tard on
s'apprête à jouer la plus grande
compétition de football sur les cadavres
de 6500 travailleurs qui ont participé à
la construction des stades climatisés 12
ans plus tard les droits humains n'ont
pas progressé au Qatar les minorités
sexuelles sont toujours persécutés les
femmes ne sont pas libres l'esclavage
continue
12 ans plus tard le climat prend la
trajectoire du Kaos global et on
continue d'organiser des grands
événements sportifs dans le déni
climatique en dépit de toutes les
alertes de toutes les catastrophes de
tous les emballements et de tous les
drames qui surviennent alors vous me
direz madame la ministre vous n'êtes pas
comptable des compromission passées mais
la France s'apprête à exporter dès
demain son savoir-faire en matière de
sécurité en le mettant au service de la
dictature cathari avec l'envoi de 220
gendarmes mais agent de sécurité civile
tous des hommes bien sûr pour ne choquer
pour ne pas choquer le rigorisme
religieux des émirs pourtant madame la
ministre au-delà du rayonnement de nos
équipes nationales le sport français
devrait être un réel vecteur
d'engagement en faveur des droits
humains et du climat ma question est
donc la même que celle que je posais à
votre prédécesseur il y a quelques mois
à l'occasion des JO au pays du génocide
ouigourd si nos joueurs n'ont pas assumé
les choix politiques de la France
allez-vous de votre côté au moins
boycotter diplomatiquement cette Coupe
du Monde de la honte et de la
compromission et allez-vous enfin
engager votre ministère dans une réelle
diplomatie sportive au service du climat
et des droits humains
pour vous répondre la parole de Kev Adam
le ministre des Sports et des Jeux
Olympiques paralympiques madame
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
dessus un rappel en effet liminaire si
vous me le permettez la décision prise
par la FIFA d'attribuer la Coupe du
Monde 2022 au Qatar a été prise il y a
12 ans
dans un tout autre contexte
notre urgence écologique elle est bien
entendu plus prégnante que jamais nous
souhaitons que le
Qatar face tout ce qu'il doit pour tenir
l'objectif de neutralité carbone qu'il a
affiché pour le Mondial
il a indiqué le pays pouvoir s'appuyer
pour cela sur un système de transport en
commun ambitieux d'ailleurs bâti pour
l'occasion avec l'expertise française et
des investissements dans les énergies
renouvelables de tout premier plan
au-delà de ça dans ce chemin vers le
Mondial nous voulons évidemment
encourager le Qatar à poursuivre son
engagement pour mettre pleinement en
oeuvre l'accord de Paris est réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre nous
sommes d'ailleurs engagés dans des
coopérations techniques pour accélérer
les efforts de ce pays dans ce sens en
prévision de la cop27 de Charmed cher
nous espérons que le Qatar pourra
soumettre une contribution nationale
réhaussée et une stratégie de concerne
davantage alignés sur l'objectif de
limitation de l'objectif de
réchauffement climatique à 1,5 degrés
s'agissant des droits humains je crois
que le combat de notre pays en
bilatérale en multilatérales dans
l'enceinte de l'OIT et avec les ONG dans
human ride Swatch dont Amnesty
International porte très haut ce combat
il a marqué de premier progrès en 2018
et en 2020 à travers une législation qui
évolue mais c'est progrès sont tout à
fait insuffisants et nous veillons à
chacune des interactions à ce pays à
promouvoir le respect de l'ensemble des
droits humains mais vous avez raison
derrière votre question c'est bien le
modèle futur que nous voulons pour nos
grands événements sportifs
internationaux et les critères qui
président à leur choix alors
localisation au cahier des charges de
ces événements deux premiers espoirs
entendons la FIFA qui appelle de ses
vœux se renforcement des critères
environnementaux dans les appels
d'offres pour les enfants
nous avons pris l'engagement pour les
Jeux Olympiques et Paralympiques des
jeux les plus écologiques de l'histoire
nous tiendrons cet engagement de la même
façon que dans la foulée du plan de
sobriété énergétique portée par la
terminer
voilà la parole est à madame Colette
mélo pour le groupe des indépendants
République et territoires
[Applaudissements]
vous allez monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé une
autre pénurie menace la France celle des
médicaments
l'alerte lancée récemment par l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
des produits de santé concernent les
traitements les plus courants du diabète
de type 2 mais c'est l'arbre qui cache
la forêt depuis janvier les ruptures
d'approvisionnement des officines
augmente de manière constante et sont en
passent d'être multipliés par deux
au-delà des antidiabétiques les
médicaments qui luttent contre
l'hypertension ou les médicaments
anticancéreux sont également concernés
par ces tensions tout comme de plus en
plus de médicaments de manière plus
générale les princesses sous les
médicaments qui n'ont pas d'alternative
thérapeutique connaissent ces
difficultés les témoignages émanant du
terrain sont clairs il manque de plus en
plus de molécules chez les pharmaciens
en 2018 déjà notre collègue Jean-Pierre
de colle avait soulevé ce problème lors
d'une mission d'information demandée par
le groupe les indépendants des pistes
d'amélioration de notre système avaient
été proposé les causes de ces pénuries
sont multiples et la gravation de la
situation est due en partie aux fortes
tensions déclenchées par la pandémie de
covid-19 et plus récemment par la guerre
en Ukraine beaucoup de nos médicaments
viennent d'Asie les matières premières
pour les fabriquer sont quasiment toutes
hors Union Européenne nos chaînes de
distribution ne sont pas assez efficaces
c'est un problème de souveraineté pour
la France et pour l'Europe nous devons
produire nos médicaments les ruptures de
stock et les tensions sur les
approvisionnements nous fragilisent nous
risquons des drames humains nous ne
pouvons pas l'accepter monsieur le
ministre quelles sont les réponses
conjoncturelles et surtout structurels
que vous comptez apporter pour lutter
contre c'est pénuries les genoux
européens n'est-il pas incontournable
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
Monsieur François Braun monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs et
sénateurs madame la sénatrice mélo le
médicament est un secteur stratégique
essentiel pour notre pays qui répond à
plusieurs enjeux renforcer notre
capacité d'innovation développer nos
capacités de production et favoriser
cette augmentation de ses capacités en
attirant des industries étrangères dans
notre pays également vous l'avez dit un
enjeu de souveraineté nationale mais
aussi un enjeu de souveraineté au sein
de l'Europe tout cela pour garantir un
meilleur accès à nos concitoyens et un
meilleur approvisionnement pour éviter
ces pénuries le gouvernement est
fortement engagé dans la suite du
président de la République pour soutenir
l'industrie du médicament à titre
d'exemple mais vous le savez des
engagements forts pour l'innovation
maintenir l'innovation que ce soit en
termes financier avec 10 milliards
d'euros qui ont été mis dans le cas du
plan et des plans à côté et également
dans le cadre de la favori pour
favoriser
l'accès aux médicaments très innovants
pour nos concitoyens
c'est un secteur en forte croissance
nous respectons là aussi les engagements
du Président de la République devant
l'industrie du médicament nous allons
même au-delà et l'année prochaine c'est
800 millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
seront mis dans cette industrie par la
Sécurité sociale tout ceci n'est pas
incompatible pour autant avec les
efforts juste et proportionnés que nous
demandons à cette industrie
nous devons en responsabilité favoriser
son développement mais je le rappelle
c'est bien le budget de la Sécurité
sociale le budget des Français qui paye
cette industrie et le gouvernement s'est
engagé à ne pas augmenter d'impôts et ne
pas diminuer non plus les droits de nos
concitoyens nous avons pour autant
entendu les remontées fortes de ce
secteur nous travaillons avec eux sur
une restructuration structurelle de
l'ensemble du secteur et sur la
meilleure moyen pour passer l'année 2023
qui est devant nous
merci de donner la parole à madame la
Présidente Sophie prima pour le groupe
les républicains
cette question s'adressait à madame la
Première ministre mais je crois que
c'est monsieur le ministre de
l'Industrie qui va me répondre monsieur
le ministre je veux avec mon collègue
Serge babary ici vous parlez au nom de
tous les chefs d'entreprise sur tous nos
territoires qui nous cessent et qui sont
tétanisés aujourd'hui par l'explosion
des coûts de l'énergie nous nous
trouvons désormais dans une situation il
est devenu préférable pour nombre
d'entreprises de cesser de produire
voire de fermer leurs portes plutôt que
de continuer à créer des richesses car
la production leur fait perdre de
l'argent certains ferment leurs usines
de trois quatre mois certains réduisent
leur production de 25 à 30 % place leur
salarié en activité par ciel à nouveau
c'est notre souveraineté industrielle
économique et même alimentaire qui est
en danger tous les secteurs sont frappés
de même que toutes les tailles
d'entreprises elles font face à cette
impasse folle soit signé des contrats à
des tarifs non soutenables
économiquement soit ne rien signer avant
fin octobre comme leur a suggéré le
président de la République en septembre
dernier et se retrouver sans contrat
sans énergie sans activité au 1er
janvier car sur le marché les contrats à
terme sont devenus inexistants les
offres quand elles existent ne sont
valables que quelques heures et ne sont
pas accessibles économiquement le marché
sans repère est imprévisible et personne
personne ne semble vouloir prendre la
bride de ce cheval devenue fou les chefs
d'entreprise sont seuls l'un de mes
critères mais qu'attends-t-il nous
mourrons et nous mourrons de mort subite
alors bien sûr un premier Bouclier a été
mis en place pour les électrons
intensives et les TPE mais je ne doute
pas que vous savez comme nous que le
dimensionnement n'est pas suffisant les
critères d'éligibilité trop strictes les
boulangers quand ils n'ont pas le bon
compteur et s'ils ont un four trop
puissant sont aujourd'hui en train de
fermer aussi Monsieur le monsieur le
ministre je vous mettais le Premier
ministre monsieur le ministre aussi
monsieur le ministre que comptez-vous
faire pour apporter une solution simple
massive et maintenant extrêmement rapide
pour soutenir nos entreprises
pour vous répondre la parole est obligé
déléguée en charge de l'Industrie
monsieur Lescure vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
Présidente prima les alertes que vous
avez je les entends aussi je suis
régulièrement sur le terrain j'ai
rencontré des entreprises dont certaines
que vous avez mentionnées qui
effectivement aujourd'hui envisage voire
même mettre en place de l'activité
partielle pour faire face à des hausses
du prix de l'énergie explosive je sais
pas si je suis en charge de dompter le
cheval mais en tout cas je participe
avec mes collègues Bruno Le Maire Agnès
renacher a trouvé des solutions et
effectivement ces solutions nous visons
à les mettre en oeuvre dans les jours
qui viennent on ne parle plus de semaine
on ne parle plus de moi on parle de jour
elles sont présentes à la fois au niveau
européen au niveau national et même au
niveau local au numéro européen vous le
savez nous travaillons pour découpler le
prix du gaz et de l'énergie et s'assurer
qu'on puisse faire baisser y compris en
intervenant sur les marchés des dérivés
pour l'année prochaine vous l'avez dit
madame la Présidente de manière à faire
baisser l'ensemble des prix du gaz et
d'É publicité pour 22 et pour 23 nous
travaillons aussi à simplifier prolonger
et amplifier le dispositif d'aide à
l'Ukraine qui a été utile pour certaines
entreprises mais qu'il avait dit n'est
aujourd'hui insuffisant dans son ampleur
et trop complexe dans ses critères nous
y travaillons là aussi avec nos
partenaires européens parce que tout ça
doit se faire au niveau européen ensuite
au niveau local moi j'ai demandé au
fonctionnaire qui sont présents dans les
territoires les commissaires aux
restructurations à l'accompagnement des
entreprises d'être au plus près des
entreprises pour les aider un à négocier
avec leur fournisseur d'énergie parce
que vous l'avez dit madame la Présidente
il est hors de question qu'on n'est pas
des contrats qui soient offerts aux
entreprises nous avons signé avec Bruno
Le Maire Agnès fanion Grégoire une
charte avec les fournisseurs d'énergie
qui se sont engagés à fournir des offres
compétitives à leurs clients si elles
leur demandent elles doivent aussi les
accompagner elles en devoir de conseils
pour les accompagner dans la durée de
manière à pouvoir les conseiller sur la
meilleure manière de dessiner leur
contrats nous intervenons à tous ces
niveaux là je voudrais aussi en profiter
pour faire un appel à la solidarité des
filières parce qu'au fond nous devons
tous contribuer à l'appui à notre
industrie qui je vous rejoins ne doit
pas être la victime collatérale de cette
guerre il faut que les distributeurs il
faut que les grands groupes il faut que
tout le monde puisse appuyer les
filières de manière à ce que l'industrie
sorte gagnant de cette crise merci
la parole est à notre collègue Nathalie
Goulet pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues deuxième clou du
cercueil après l'intervention de Sophie
prima cette fois-ci pour plaider pour la
filière agricole qui est lourdement
frappée par la crise énergétique avec
évidemment l'augmentation des intrants
des ruptures de contrat
d'approvisionnement d'énergie notamment
des fournisseurs alternatifs ce secteur
semble oublier alors que d'autres sont
plus attentifs à d'autres secteurs et
les agriculteurs douloureusement cette
injustice le cas par exemple de la
coopérative biocert dans l'heure 280
adhérents 26 dans l'Orne facture
énergétique
285000 euros aujourd'hui plus d'un
million si rien n'est fait ceci est
évidemment insoutenable Sophie prima a
très bien expliqué le dispositif il en
est de même pour la filière équipe chère
au président Larcher et pour les jeunes
agriculteurs récemment installés qui ne
peuvent bénéficier de dispositif en
place mal adapté n'oublions pas les
suicides d'agriculteurs et les nombreux
drames personnels notre souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre dont
vous êtes évidemment chargé et menacé
quelle mesure allez vous prendre et
quelle mesure avez-vous déjà prise pour
soutenir les agriculteurs dans cette
période extrêmement difficile
la parole est au ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire Monsieur marcéno Merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Goulet cette question
effectivement fait ok écho pardon à la
question qui a été posée par la
présidente prima sous le pendant
Agriculture et Agroalimentaire avec une
spécificité parfois j'y reviendrai que
la spécificité d'avoir une saisonnalité
et une incapacité en plus à rompre la
chaîne de production dans le dans
l'agriculture la situation a été décrite
n'y reviendrait pas on a travaillé je
crois avec vous madame la sénatrice sur
l'entreprise biossaire pourrait essayer
de trouver des solutions globalement
quelques éléments sur le court terme en
complément ce quasiment collègue Lescure
sur le court terme la charte qui a été
signé par l'ensemble des opérateurs pour
fournir obligatoirement une offre pour
conseiller et pour faire en sorte que la
modération puisse l'emporter deuxième
élément le niveau européen effectivement
nous attendons des réponses dans les
jours qui viennent pour faire en sorte
qu'on puisse décorer les prix de
l'énergie gaz électricité parce que ça
c'est un levier puissant c'est un levier
puissant évidemment au niveau européen
nous simplifions enfin l'aide aux
énergies aux entreprises et ergo
archives en l'adaptant mieux à ce qui
était la réalité y compris je le dis de
la saisonnalité de les industries ou
alimentaires je pense à une filière pour
être emblématique et celle de la
betterave où on voit bien qu'il y a une
période où on a besoin de plus
d'électricité que d'autres ou d'énergie
que d'autres et le dispositif entonné
malcompte et donc on a réajusté
dispositif enfin il est massifié dans
son montant puisqu'on est passé on a
doublé pour chaque catégorie
d'entreprises de 2 à 4 millions de 25 à
50 millions et de 50 à 100 millions
enfin dernier élément et là c'est plutôt
sur le moyen long terme madame la
sénatrice on a besoin aussi de
travailler à faire en sorte que vous en
avez parlé d'être moins dépendant d'un
certain nombre de facteurs de production
je pense à l'énergie et je pense aussi à
l'intérieur de l'énergie aux intrants en
particulier aux intrants azotés parce
que la situation dans laquelle l'Europe
s'est mise d'une dépendance trop
importante fait en sorte que nous avons
besoin de reconquérir cette souveraineté
donc des mesures de court terme et des
mesures d'accompagnement de moyens et
long terme pour l'ensemble des filières
agricoles et agroalimentaires et vous le
savez madame la sénatrice le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
sous l'autorité de la première ministre
et le ministère de l'agriculture est
quotidiennement mobilisé pour essayer de
répondre aux besoins de chacune des
filières merci
madame vous voulez
je pense qu'il faudrait
pour les entreprises au niveau
des lecteurs les élus mais aussi la BPI
la banque des territoires la MSA en fait
tout ce qu'on peut mettre en place pour
des mesures d'urgence et aussi la
protection des individus je pense aussi
que madame la Première ministre a
indiqué une taxe sur les super profits
je pense que ça va être bienvenu et
qu'elle servira aussi à améliorer les
dispositifs qui permettent d'indemniser
en tous les cas de soutenir cette
filière en tous les cas sachez que nous
sommes extrêmement mobilisés qui a une
urgence je pense notamment aux jeunes
agriculteurs qui ne disposent d'aucune
ancienneté pour bénéficier des boucliers
qui sont actuellement en place donc
c'est vraiment important et c'est
vraiment urgent merci pour eux merci de
donner la parole de notre collègue Eric
Bocquet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste merci
monsieur le Président Madame Laurent
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
depuis un certain temps nos compatriotes
regardent avec effarons tourner le
compteur des pompes à essence et pendant
ce temps-là les actionnaires regardent
grimper les chiffres les dividendes avec
ravissement les prix des carburants
s'emballent les spéculations sévit et
total énergie sans riches y compris
grâce à l'argent public du bouclier
tarifaire l'entreprise enregistrée plus
de 10 milliards de dividendes au premier
semestre de cette année ce qui valut
d'ailleurs aux actionnaires le 28
septembre dernier de bénéficier d'un
dividende d'exceptionnel de 2,6
milliards d'euros total énergie
deviendra demain totale bénéfice les
salariés des groupes pétroliers
demandent légitimement leur part de
cette réussite entre guillemets et
revendique une hausse de leur salaire la
satisfaction des revendications des
salariés pour Total énergie
représenterait une somme de 140 millions
d'euros soit 1,4% des profits du seul
premier semestre monsieur le ministre je
pense qu'il est temps de faire pression
sur les directions des groupes total
énergie et exones mobiles leur demander
aimablement un geste de bonnes volonté à
l'évidence cela ne suffit pas d'autant
plus que face aux salariés le
gouvernement brandit la menace
inacceptable de la réquisition
pour vous répondre la parole à Olivier
vérante-parole du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateurs Bocquet
de pas votre appartenance politique de
par votre le combat que vous avez mené
je vous sais plus attaché que qui compte
autre ici à la qualité du dialogue
social et au respect des accords obtenus
par le dialogue social monsieur le
sénateur je vous invite à envisager une
situation qui ferait que des syndicats
majoritaires obtiennent un accord
majoritaire avec un employeur portant
sur une hausse de salaire et qu'à
l'issue de cet accord majoritaire un
syndicat non signataire non seulement
aux deux syndicats non signataires
minoritaires je crois que le dialogue
social c'est le fait majoritaire et je
crois que les comics soutiennent cela et
je le soutiens aussi et le gouvernement
aussi à l'issue de cela des syndicats
non signataires décident non seulement
de contester cet accord mais en plus de
bloquer l'outil de travail bloquant
ainsi aussi l'outil de travail pour les
salariés qui eux-mêmes se sont engagés à
travers un accord majoritaire pour une
hausse et salaire je vous invite juste à
envisager cette situation pour ce
qu'elle a d'inhabituelle de non
conformes aux droits du travail non
conforme sociale du point de vue du
gouvernement cela justifie le recours à
des réquisitions qui n'ont rien
d'abusifs qui sont des réquisitions qui
seront juste nécessaires de manière à ce
que l'outil de travail l'outil productif
puisse retrouver ses plaines fonctions
et ses plaines missions et voyez que la
première ministre fait d'ailleurs le
distingo avec la situation d'un autre
groupe pour lequel un accord n'a pas
encore été trouvé et croyez à
l'engagement du gouvernement pour faire
en sorte que tout le monde se mette
autour de la table et discute de les
conditions d'un accord qui nous
permettrait une sortie de crise enfin
permettez-moi encore d'insister sur ce
point-là monsieur sénateur ça ne vous
est je crois jamais arriver en tant que
sénateur ou élu local d'aller contester
un accord en bonne et due forme signé
par des syndicats je le répète
majoritaire parce que le mot est
important
les salariés des groupes concernés ne
demandent pas une hausse de 52% de leurs
revenus à l'image de celle que le PDG de
Total énergie c'est octroyé il demande
leur part légitime en cette rentrée de
forte inflation la question du pouvoir
d'achat est devenue la première
préoccupation de nos concitoyens comment
pourrait-on s'en étonner vous allez
déposer deux amendements en loi de
finances qui devraient dégager nous
dit-on 200 millions d'euros c'est très
très loin du compte il faut taxer
fortement les super profits pour aider
les salariés les retraités les
entreprises et les collectivités le
ministre Bruno Le Maire disait la
semaine dernière dans une interview à la
Gazette je crois je préfère le ciblage
au saupoudrage sachez que de ce côté de
l'hémicycle nous préférons le partage au
bricolage
merci je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Michael et colimo est ok pour
le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
qui sont dans la tribu de l'honneur
voilà Monsieur le
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues
en préambule je tiens à remercier
l'action du gouvernement et en
particulier celle du ministre
Jean-François Carenco
pour sa bienveillance à recevoir la
délégation des élus de Wallis-et-Futuna
cette semaine à Paris
mais aussi pour l'impulsion donnée à la
reprise des travaux du quai de l'herbe
qui est un poumon pour l'île de foot
en réponse à ma demande de juillet
dernier bien sûr
je voudrais aussi profiter de cette
période de consultation générale
pour attirer votre attention sur la
situation sanitaire à Wallis Escoumins
comme vous le savez monsieur le ministre
depuis 2005 17 ans aucune politique de
prévention n'a été mise en place par
l'agence de santé ce qui a permis aux
maladies telles que le diabète et les
maladies cardio-vasculaires de se
développer sur le terrain le rapport
IGAS de 2019
avait pourtant préconisé de mettre
l'accent sur la prévention
mais ce rapport est resté très officieux
et ce au détriment de notre population
je souhaite ici m'assurer que la
conférence de santé se tiendra au
premier semestre 2023
et associés à toutes les instances
locales et l'ensemble de la population
d'autre part monsieur le ministre le
lancement du volley santé du Conseil
national de la refondation doit aussi
être l'occasion de restaurer le lien de
confiance auront pu entre la population
et l'Agence de santé
ne sont pas entendues les professionnels
de santé fuient le territoire
je souhaite enfin attirer votre
attention sur deux autres situations
prioritaires
premièrement celle des dialysés qui ont
besoin du renouvellement de oui
générateurs démondialyse devenus
obsolètes
et d'un véhicule adapté pour leur
transport
deuxièmement la concrétisation du projet
d'epad avec un copilotage est un
territoire
aussi monsieur le ministre au regard de
ces éléments
comment le gouvernement entend t-il
aider Wallis espna à se doter d'un
système de santé et d'une organisation
des soins adaptés aux besoins de la
population je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole du cas monsieur
ministre de la Santé de la préventionne
chez le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
culino est ok vous connaissez mon
attachement pour les territoires
ultramarins et leurs problèmes liés au
système de santé je l'ai dit dès que je
suis arrivé à ce ministère attachement
que que je partage avec Jean-François
Carenco et nous suivons de près la
problématique de l'ensemble des
territoires d'outre-mer et bien entendu
Wallis-et-Futuna ne sera pas laissé pour
compte dans ces dans ces préoccupations
les problèmes sont sur le terrain j'ai
aussi l'habitude de dire que les
solutions sont sur le terrain et c'est
là qu'il faut aller les chercher dans ce
cadre le CNR santé qui a démarré la
semaine dernière
aura pleinement son rôle sur le
territoire de Wallis-et-Futuna en
associant les élus les citoyens les
professionnels de santé tout ceci sous
le couvert pour l'organisation de
l'Agence de santé et l'Agence de Santé
prendra toute sa part pour organiser ses
réunions bien entendu la conférence de
santé qui va se tenir et tout à fait
dans le cadre de ce CNR santé
sur le volet prévention vous savez que
c'est une politique à laquelle je tiens
beaucoup en tant que ministre de la
santé et de la prévention mais également
en tant que médecin je ne peux accepter
une situation où la prévention est
insatisfaisante et ne permet pas de
répondre aux besoins de santé de la
population je rappelle ici que 4 cancers
sur 10 et 8 maladies cardiovasculaires
sur 10 pourraient être évité simplement
par une bonne santé c'est-à-dire manger
correctement respirer correctement et
faire de l'exercice physique c'est ce à
quoi nous devons aboutir sur l'ensemble
du territoire national et bien entendu
aux outre-mer concernant le rapport et
gaz de 2019 juste pour vous rappeler
quand même que nous avons commencé à
mettre en place un pôle santé publique
et prévention au sein de l'agence que
des personnels ont été recrutés et que
les travaux vont enfin certes démarrer
sur une politique de prévention plus
ambitieuse concernant la problématique
de l'hémodialyse je vais voir de près ce
que vous évoquez sur ces problématiques
de postes démodialyse je vais rappeler
aussi que
pour Futuna des travaux en débutés pour
un centre d'emodialyse qui seront fini
fin 2023 à 20 d'éviter des transferts
entre Futuna et Wallis des paris
évacuation sanitaires les problèmes sont
sur le terrain les solutions aussi j'en
suis persuadé avec l'ensemble des
citoyens et les élus
la parole est notre collègue Laurent
Duplomb pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le ministre division de moitié
de la production de pommes explosion des
importations de poulet polonais et de
tomates marocaines chute des surfaces de
blé recul du cheptel laitier faute d'un
revenu suffisant des éleveurs c'est
incontestable la ferme France produit de
moins en moins depuis 2017 vous prenez
le tout monté en gamme plus de
contraintes et plus de charge quitte à
importer davantage depuis le discours de
Rungis du président voilà votre
politique vous faites fausse route vous
mettez en danger notre souveraineté
alimentaire pour tous les Français en
condamnant certains de nos citoyens a
acheté que des produits importés on
marche sur la tête notre manque de
compétitivité est la racine de nos mots
coût de la main d'oeuvre sur
transposition et sur administration
manque d'investissement signature
d'accord de libre-échange qui au lieu de
protéger condamne nos agriculteurs sans
parler du climat politique médiatique
délétère avec son flot de critiques
voilà le mal français monsieur le
ministre vous devez enfin agir il faut
inverser cette tendance que comptez-vous
faire
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire merci merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateurs Duplomb je vois d'abord saluer
la qualité du travail ce qui fait cause
vous avez fait au travail que vous avez
fait au travers d'un rapport avec deux
de vos collègues et je vous salue la
qualité de ce rapport qui pose un
certain nombre de diagnostics d'ailleurs
le diagnostic que vous posez parce que
vous avez eu l'honnêteté intellectuelle
de le faire il porte sur 32 années
puisqu'il remonte à 90 sur cette affaire
de souveraineté c'est si président de la
République à 17 ministres qui se sont
succédés donc c'est manifestement un
sujet depuis longtemps qui est dit sur
la table vous évoquez plusieurs
questions dans ce rapport je vais en
évoquer rapidement dans le temps imparti
quelques-unes d'abord il y a la question
de la rémunération nous avons depuis
2017 au travers de deux lois successives
également corrigés par égalité de faire
en sorte que nous ayons bien un débat au
travers de la rémunération ça avait
porté ses fruits jusqu'à ce que la crise
ukrainienne arrive mais pour la première
fois depuis 10 ans la rémunération avait
augmenté et on sait très bien que la
rémunération c'est la
du maintien du monde agricole le
deuxième sujet est sur lequel je
voudrais insister c'est que depuis 2017
nous avons mis en oeuvre deux programmes
massivement le premier c'est le plan
France relance qui se termine 1,5
milliards d'euros qui ont été quasiment
totalement concernés je viens de faire
la reventilation des dernières
enveloppes et donc c'est un milliard 5
d'euros pour moderniser l'outil de
production et dans France France 2030
c'est près de 3 milliards d'euros qui
seront mis à disposition pour
l'innovation la recherche et
l'adaptation de l'agriculture troisième
élément il faut qu'on travaille sur la
souveraineté sur les questions vous
connaissez bien ce sujet monsieur le
sénateur qui sont les questions d'eau au
travers du varen de l'eau trois
dispositifs le système assurantiel sur
lequel vous avez travaillé
particulièrement ici au Sénat faire en
sorte qu'on puisse solidifier le système
d'assurance deuxième élément
l'adaptation des pratiques troisième
élément c'est l'accès à l'eau il faut
désormais déployer les projets parce que
sans eau il y aura pas d'agriculture et
désormais il faut qu'on le fasse
concrètement sur le terrain enfin il me
semble que il faut qu'on travaille sur
deux sujets complémentaires l'adaptation
au dérèglement climatique qui vient peu
puissamment impacter qui peut avoir des
conséquences sur la souveraineté des
modèles de production qui sont chahutés
on l'a vu singulièrement cet été et puis
dernier élément il y aura pas de
souveraineté alimentaire et pas de
souveraineté tout court si on n'arrive
pas à procéder au renouvellement des
générations et donc il faut leur donner
des perspectives
monsieur Duplomb
monsieur le ministre tout ça
malheureusement c'est des mots et on
voit pas beaucoup d'action monsieur le
ministre ce qui nous arrive sur
l'énergie nous allons le connaître sur
l'alimentation alors je ne suis pas un
arc simplement paysan mais comme
beaucoup de Français j'en ai marre de
cette technocratie abrutissante qui
finira pour résoudre notre problème de
souveraineté de nous condamner à ne
manger qu'un jour par semaine plutôt que
de la décroissance il nous faut un vrai
choc de compétitivité madame la Première
ministre après le théâtre guignol du col
roulé ou de la doudoune enfilez enfin
vos bottes pour comprendre la situation
préoccupante dans laquelle notre
agriculture se trouve merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Jérôme du Rhin pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur la commission
des Lois du Sénat décidait la création
d'une mission d'information pour
examiner l'opportunité de la
réorganisation de la police judiciaire
on aurait pu imaginer que cette
initiative qui a inspiré l'Assemblée
nationale vous permette de recréer les
conditions d'un dialogue serein que
constate-t-on un mois après la
mobilisation de la PJ que le DGPN a
minoré ne faiblit pas fâché par une
vidéo ce dernier a d'ailleurs limogé le
patron de la PJ marseillaise résultat la
contestation s'étend et devient visible
dans la rue vous citez des rapports
parlementaires et des ministres pour
justifier votre réforme mais aucun ne
ces rapports et aucun de vos
prédécesseurs n'était parvenu à
inquiéter l'ensemble de la PJ même la PJ
parisienne dont vous rappelez qu'elle
n'est pas concernée soutient le
mouvement vous incriminez la proximité
des élections syndicales pour justifier
ce climat tout en affirmant que tous les
syndicats soutiennent votre réforme hier
même les très discrets procure on
renouvelé leur opposition à cette
réforme considérant que ce projet
constitue une remise en cause de la
place accordée à l'autorité judiciaire
gardienne de la liberté individuelle
dans un état de droit monsieur le
ministre n'est-ce pas le moment de
revoir votre copie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur les
outre-mer monsieur Darmanin merci
Monsieur Président Madame et Messieurs
les créateurs monsieur le sénateur nous
travaillons en ce moment même dans un
esprit je crois à constructif sur la loi
d'orientation et programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur et nous avons
eu des longs débats mais évidemment
devant vos collègues je veux revenir sur
cette réforme de la police nationale qui
est nécessaire et qui est attendu depuis
plus de 35 ans par divers rapports 7
j'en ai compté sénatoriaux de toute
tendance politique confondues j'en ai
fait la démonstration hier et lancer par
le ministre Joxe
alors revenons au ministre Jox
j'en viens aux questions posées par
Monsieur Hennel monsieur le Président
dit le ministre jeu de ce 26 novembre
1990 au Sénat débat en faisant foi le
fait de nommer un directeur
départemental de la police nationale a
été accueilli avec curiosité parfois
inquiétude y compris chez certains
fonctions de la police nationale
notamment les commissaires
cela ne porte rien à atteinte monsieur
gardez-so au principe fondamental selon
lequel la police judiciaire est à la
disposition de la justice et travaille
bien sûr sur le contrôle du parquet ou
sur les instructions d'une commission
obligatoire délivrée par un juge
d'instruction aujourd'hui les services
de la préjudiciaire sont placés sur
l'autorité des chefs de service
régionaux de la police judiciaire et du
scpj le préfet en tant que chef de
l'ensemble des services de l'État est
parfois des services ministère de
l'Intérieur dans le département aura
autorité sur eux dans l'exact mesures où
il peut avoir autorité sur des services
de fonctionnaires jusqu'au moment précis
où ces derniers se trouvent placés de
par la loi sur l'autorité de la justice
à cet égard malgré les inquiétudes
exprimées par les fonctions de police
rien ne sera modifié il est vrai que
c'est Monsieur Pasqua qui a mis fin à
cette excellente réforme
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre renvoyez à ce qui
s'est passé il y a 30 ans je vous parle
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui notre
mission c'est notorial se prononcera au
fond mais il y a à minima un problème de
méthode les policiers ne réagissent pas
par corporatisme ce qui est en jeu c'est
la séparation des pouvoirs et le modèle
français d'enquête la police judiciaire
sous l'autorité du préfet c'est le
risque d'abandonner les enquêtes
complexes la criminité organisée devant
le flux inexorable du quotidien monsieur
Darmanin on connaît votre grand talent
mais aujourd'hui à part vous personne ne
semble soutenir cette réforme
merci
la parole
est à notre collègue Jacques gros Perrin
pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale le 13 juillet
dernier je vous interrogé en commission
de la culture sur mes vive inquiétude
concernant votre ministère les
situations de l'école en France après
votre nomination je vous demandais de
nous rassurer trois mois plus tard mes
inquiétudes demeurent le président de la
République a décidé lui-même de lancer
l'année scolaire en réunissant les
acteurs et les réacteurs d'académie
pensez-vous que les lampes pour
transformer l'école doit être si
puissants qui ne puisse venir que du
chef de l'État cette verticalité
interroge sur votre rôle et vos marges
de manœuvre tout en posant de nouveau la
question rupture ou continuité après
votre prédécesseur monsieur le ministre
les fait les réalités ou rattrapent la
rentrée scolaire n'a pas été à la
hauteur il n'avait pas d'enseignant
devant chaque classe et d'aucun était
même formé en quatre jours les
difficultés de terrain se multiplient
des enchantements générales des
enseignants et aux et signalements pour
atteinte à la laïcité votre
communication prudente elle a encore
insuffisante
la communauté éducative a besoin de
directives clair d'être soutenu d'une
volonté politique ferme ou récent propos
à l'étranger vont également inquiété
vous avez monsieur le ministre pensif
pouvoir affirmer à New York du site qui
est des traces d'anti-américanisme dans
les discours politique français vous
avez suggéré la possibilité d'évoquer
avec nuance les inégalités raciales dans
notre pays non monsieur le ministre la
France n'est pas raciste nous sommes
nous aussi aux questions sensibles aux
questions d'inégalité n'abîmez pas les
trois génocides fondateurs cessez de
vous positionner comme universitaire
militante ne tendez pas de nous imposer
un wokisme de salon chair à notre
président retaillaux incompatible avec
vos responsabilités politiques soyez
ministres et enfin la seule question qui
s'impose monsieur le ministre quel est
votre vision de l'école où voulez vous
emmener les enseignants et nos enfants
pour vous répondre la parole étape
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse Monsieur
papendaye Merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur groupé 1 monsieur
le sénateur ou ma vie interrogé à ce
sujet devant la commission des affaires
culturelles et de l'éducation et je veux
bien répondre à nouveau mais il est
important de prendre le temps en deux
minutes ce sera difficile de se plonger
dans la réflexion et de ne pas
simplement extraire des citations
approximatives que j'ai vu circuler ici
et là j'ai déjà dit et j'ai eu
l'occasion de le redire à quel point
j'étais moi-même un enfant de la
République et que je devais à peu près
tout à l'école publique et je demeure
profondément reconnaissant à son égard
je suis aussi de ceux qui estiment que
lutter contre les différentes formes de
discrimination contre le racisme contre
l'antisémitisme ou la haine anti LGBT
n'affaiblit pas la République mais la
renforce c'est une manière pour moi
d'exprimer concrètement notre
attachement aux valeurs qui sont les
nôtres celles de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité et de laïcité la laïcité j'y
tiens la loi de 2004 est et sera
respecté fermement et avec transparence
je vous ai dit aussi mon attachement une
république fidèle à ses valeurs celle
des droits humains il y a une république
qui non contente d'inscrire ces
principes aux frontispices de ces
bâtiments les met en oeuvre en tant que
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse je ne suis pas simplement
attaché à la lettre mais aussi à la mise
en oeuvre concrète des politiques de
cohésion sociale de réussite pour tous
les élèves et d'égalité des chances
alors vous le voyez monsieur le sénateur
ici point de hockisme de salon mais mon
seul attachement en tant que citoyen en
tant que ministre aux valeurs un celle
de la République
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est le ministre nous sommes ici
tous des enfants de la République tous
les enfants de la République vous pouvez
pas vous Tarier de l'être simplement
mais je tiens à vous dire néanmoins
néanmoins vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
question sur votre vision de l'école et
les Français attendent la vision de
l'école en 2008 mais on attend ça fait
quelques mois que vous avez été élu en
tout cas choisi par le Président de la
République et enfin les défis sont en
tout cas vos mots ne répondent à ce
moment ni à l'effondrement la
connaissance et la crise de la
transmission ni aux immenses défis
posées à l'école monsieur le ministre
apporté à votre ministère apporter aux
Français la sérénité dont nous avons
besoin merci
la parole est à notre collègue Pierre
Antoine Lévy pour le groupe de l'Union
tantrique
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à la
ministre chargée de l'organisation
territoriale et de la santé madame la
ministre nombreux sont les maires
confrontés
face à cette situation les mères
cherchent désespérément des médecins
français ou européens pour leurs
administrer mais devant les échecs à
répétition il se mettent finalement en
quête de médecin orunion européenne où
sont sollicités par ces mêmes médecins
pour venir
si certains ont des pistes pour faire
venir un médecin étranger francophone
ils abandonnent souvent leur démarche
découragé par les difficultés
administratives c'est à se demander si
tout n'est pas fait pour décourager leur
venue en des asphyxiants par des
démarches complexes dont il n'arrive
souvent pas voir l'issue pour ne pas
paraître tous centré sur mon département
bien qu'il soit tout aussi concerné je
vais prendre l'exemple de la commune des
Pyrénées-Orientales la Tour de France
mes collègues gens sur les François
Calvi connaissent très certainement
cette histoire
cette ville n'a pu me laisser un
journaliste depuis le 22 octobre 2021
situation devenue malheureusement banale
dans nos territoires ruraux le maire
avait pourtant réussi à trouver un
médecin pour sa commune mais celui-ci
est libanais et exerce actuellement à
Beyrouth le docteur en question est prêt
à quitter le Liban pour s'installer à la
Tour de France il a 30 ans d'expérience
il a fait en plus une partie de ses
études à Lyon seulement voilà depuis le
début de l'année le ministère de la
Santé bloque son dossier laissant le
mettre dans l'incompréhension
cet exemple d'une aspect isolé je suis
bien ensemble de nos territoires ruraux
qui est confronté à ces difficultés
contenu d'attention qui règne en France
en matière d'accès aux soins ne
devrions-nous pas songer à favoriser
l'implantation de ces médecins non
communautaire en facilitant de façon
dérogatoire les procédures
administratives sur la porterait ainsi
une réponse même partielle la crise des
désirs médicaux pourquoi par exemple ne
pas organiser 5 indices concours
d'évaluation des connaissances et
compétences par an au lieu de une à deux
actuellement répondant à la pénurie de
médecins passera forcément par de
multiples dispositifs celui-ci en est un
parmi tant d'autres voici madame la
ministre pourriez-vous nous indiquer ce
que compte faire le Gouvernement en la
matière je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est à la ministre
délégué en charge de l'organisation
territoriale et des professions de santé
madame Firmin labodo monsieur le
Président Mesdames et sénatrices
messieurs le sénateur monsieur le
sénateur Lévy la loi de 2019 portant sur
l'organisation et transformation du
notre système de santé dite ots a posé
les bases d'un nouveau dispositif de
reconnaissance des tas des
professionnels ex européenne comme vous
l'avez signalé avec deux procédures
distinctes la première procédure avec un
nom
usuel pas très joli je vous le concède
le stock pour les praticiens qui
exercaient dans nos établissements de
santé avant 2019 et parfois depuis très
longtemps a été mise en place une
procédure de régularisation pour
s'assurer de leur compétences une
procédure pour le flux pour les
praticiens souhaitant venir depuis 2019
a été mise en place pour une épreuve de
vérification des connaissances avec un
parcours de consolidation de la pratique
la crise sanitaire a malheureusement
empêché l'organisation des commissions
d'autorisation en raison de la forte
mobilisation des membres du jury qui
sont des professionnels de santé et des
candidats eux-mêmes qui sont des
professionnels de santé dans les
établissements santé et on peut s'en
féliciter au 1er octobre 2022 il reste
2400 dossiers à traiter selon cette
procédure à la demande du gouvernement
je tiens à saluer l'engagement de
l'ordre des médecins et de la Commission
nationale de gestion de mettre et de
renforcer les dispositifs des effectifs
afin de traiter le plus grand nombre de
dossiers avant la date butoir du 31
décembre 2022 posé dans la loi au TSS
malheureusement nous savons que c'est
2400 dossiers nous pourront être traités
c'est pour ça que le gouvernement a
déposé dans le cadre du PLFSS un
amendement qui prolonge jusqu'au 31 mars
2023 la gestion de ce de ce stock au 31
mars 2023 le stock sera sera effectif
sera géré sur la procédure du flux nous
serons vigilants la première session a
eu lieu en 2022 nous sommes en train de
tirer les retours de sexe des
expériences d'expérience de cette
gestion de flux et nous allons en lien
avec les ARS le cnome le CNG et le
syndicat des Padu répondre au mieux à
cette gestion du flux sur lequel nous
devons apporter des améliorations
merci je vais donner votre la parole de
notre collègue Olivier Pacaud
pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
un brin de cohérence c'est de bon sens
n'a jamais nuire surtout à un
gouvernement alors où la déchéance
populaire envers la parole publique et
atteint des sommets mieux vaut une
République exemplaire permettez-moi donc
de m'interroger sur une contradiction de
votre gouvernance une règle certes
informelle mais inlassablement répété
depuis 25 ans veut qu'un ministre
abandonne c'est mandat exécutif locaux
avec une mission à un objectif simple se
consacrer entièrement à sa mission
gouvernementale l'immense majorité de
votre gouvernement s'est plié à cette
règle rejoignant ainsi les
parlementaires pour qui le nom cumule et
non pas une règle mais une loi que le
précédent gouvernement auquel vous
apparteniez à refuser d'assouplir l'an
dernier cependant il reste quelques
récalcitrant
mère président d'assemblée ultra-marine
président d'agglomération et même
président d'un département dans le cas
du ministre des Armées y aura-t-il donc
des ministres privilégiés de fortes
têtes capricieux un problème d'autorité
de votre part Madame le Ministre
comptez-vous enfin faire appliquer cette
règle que le mini le chef de l'État
lui-même avait rappelé en 2017 allez
vous faire démissionner de leur mandats
locaux les ministres concernés
la parole est comme ils disent de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer Gérald
Darmanin
les bras les braconniers étant les
meilleurs garde de chasse dans la
famille de répondre à votre question
monsieur le sénateur Pacaud d'abord je
voudrais vous dire que au nom du
gouvernement et bien sûr de la première
ministre les règles seront respectées
plusieurs ministres ont déjà démissionné
de leur fonction exécutives et ils ont
quelques semaines à demander la première
ministre pour pouvoir convoquer leurs
assemblées délibérantes afin de
démissionner toutes et tous de leur
exécutif tout en restant évidemment
conseiller municipal conseil
départemental au conseil régional
j'espère que vous ne reprochez pas mon
gouvernement que vous évoqués parfois un
peu distant du terrain d'être par
ailleurs élu faudra pas non plus que ce
soit une retard vérité ici
mensonge au-delà monsieur le sénateur
Paco une fois que j'ai rappelé cette
règle qui je crois peut vous plaire j'ai
compris qu'il y avait aussi une question
de départementale dans votre question et
que sans doute la ministre de votre
département auquel vous partagiez
j'imagine un moment de sympathie lors de
l'assemblée des maires de samedi dernier
dans le l'Oise purée si vous rappelez
que la règle évoquée bien sûr est
informelle mais a toujours connu
le ministre Jean-Yves Le Drian a été
ministre de la Défense tout en étant
président de la Région Bretagne il me
semble d'ailleurs que le président
Nicolas Sarkozy a été très longuement
ministre de l'intérieur tout en étant
maire de Neuilly président du conseil
départemental des 13
quelques témoins monsieur Barouin a
longtemps été maire de droite tout en
étant ministre monsieur Pacaud monsieur
Pacaud monsieur Pacaud est voté évoqué
une règle que les moins de 25 ans
pouvaient pas connaître mais comme nous
avons je crois le même compagnonnage et
il a sans doute oublié un certain nombre
de dispositions qui lui déplaisait
je sais pas quoi
madame la Première ministre je félicite
le bon élève l'ancien maire de Tourcoing
d'avoir répondu et nous avons tous pris
notre que les ministres rebelles
démissionneraient bientôt reste dans
nous ne voulons pas de parole nous
voulons des actes c'est ce que mérite
nos citoyens et nos territoires et la
question d'autorité est d'exemplarité
sont la clé du problème comment
voulez-vous Madame le Ministre être obéi
entre guillemets des français quand un
ministre effrontément Bafou la règle et
quel comble de voir l'armée ou le sens
de la hiérarchie et de la discipline
sont les valeurs cardinales dirigées par
un ministre rebelle à la conclure
commune voilà l'exemplarité de se
proclame pas elle se pratique
merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Gisèle Jourda pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et République
c'est le président ma question s'adresse
à Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères
face à l'internationalisation du conflit
à l'Ukraine à sa dramatique
densification
quels sont les initiatives les actions
que compte mener la France
allons-nous continuer à rechercher une
issue diplomatique allons-nous décider
d'augmenter notre contribution
humanitaire financière ou militaire cela
en prend le chemin car la France vient
d'annoncer qu'elle renforçait sa
présence militaire en Roumanie dans le
cadre de l'OTAN allons-nous tenter de
peser sur le G7 mais que peut décider le
G7 réunit en urgence sinon affichage de
solidarité allons nous faire la
promotion de nouvelles sanctions
je partage les mots du président de la
République nous insistons à un
changement profond de la nature de cette
guerre et ce surtout car le Bélarus
s'apprête à véritablement devenir la
base armée et le faire de lance de la
politique russe dans la gradation du
conflit
il serait bien avisé de ne pas entrer
dans la guerre ce sont vos mots madame
la ministre
milk ce n'est pas seulement le nom des
accords qui n'ont pas abouti c'est
surtout la capitale d'un pays martyre
dans l'angle mort de nos actualités
alors que s'il joue la vie de plusieurs
centaines de prisonniers politiques je
veux faire raisonner le nom et saluer le
courage madame la ministre à l'homme du
conflit qui nous plonge tous à leur
internationale européenne comment
apprécier le fléchissement de la
politique du Bélarus je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la Ministre de l'Europe de faire
étrangère Madame Catherine Colonna
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Center madame la sénatrice
Jourdain vous avez raison depuis lundi
et encore aujourd'hui la Russie a lancé
une série de frappe sur le territoire
ukrainien qui vise principalement les
infrastructures civiles et qui ont sans
doute pour objectif également
d'atteindre le moral de la population
ukrainienne alors la France la réaffirmé
son soutien à l'Ukraine se poursuivra et
ils sont ici ils s'intensifie enfin nous
aidons l'Ukraine dans sa résistance
militaire mais nous l'aidons aussi dans
sa résilience civile sa capacité à tenir
et sa capacité à tenir notamment à
l'approche de l'hiver
notre soutien porte sur tous les
domaines économiques à hauteur déjà de 2
milliards d'euros humanitaires avec pour
la France plus de 200 millions d'euros
mobilisés et bien sûr militaires avec de
nouvelles décisions encore annoncées par
le ministre des Armées vous l'avez dit
mais c'est aussi un soutien politique et
diplomatique qui se poursuit car il y a
un agresseur et un agressé alors hier
les dirigeants du G7 ont condamné les
dernières attaques russes qu'ils ont
qualifiés de crimes de guerre et on dit
que leur responsable devront rendre des
comptes ce soir ou dans la nuit
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
se prononcera sans ambiguïté sur
l'annexion illégale le territoire
ukrainien par la Russie montrant une
fois de plus son isolement l'isolement
de la Russie et je réponds indirectement
madame la sénatrice à votre question sur
le Belarus qui en effet ne doit pas
s'engager davantage dans son soutien à
l'opération
illégal menée par la Russie et ce
soutien c'est aussi le soutien de
l'Union européenne qui a mobilisé déjà
plus de 9 milliards d'euros qui a porté
la facilité européenne de paix de
milliards et demi d'euros et qui a
adopté déjà 8 séries de sanctions pour
peser sur l'effort de guérus je vous le
dis il y aura si nécessaire d'autres
sanctions ce soutien s'inscrira dans la
durée pour que l'Ukraine recouvre sa
souveraineté je vous le redis madame la
sénatrice après le président de la
République après la première ministre
nous serons à côté de l'Ukraine aussi
longtemps que nécessaire je vous
remercie
très brièvement madame la ministre
n'oublions pas qu'il faut absolument
stopper cette guerre sortir certes du
conflit et vous en avez donné donc les
perspectives mais surtout n'oublions pas
de retrouver des perspectives de paix et
pour retrouver des perspectives de paix
après avoir stoppé la guerre il faut
savoir continuer à se parler
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Cédric Vial pour le groupe les
républicains
merci ce Président mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur papenga
il me disent de l'éducation nationale et
de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre l'inclusion des
élèves en situation du handicap à
l'école est une priorité c'est aussi un
défi pour lequel nous sommes tous
mobilisés depuis la loi de 2005 pourtant
cette rentrée scolaire ne s'est pas
déroulée pour beaucoup de ses enfants
comme toutes les autres
en effet depuis septembre et suite à une
décision de justice sollicité et obtenue
par votre prédécesseur l'Etat c'est
désengagé du suivi et de la prise en
charge de ses enfants a besoin
particulier sur le temps périscolaire et
celui de la cantine s'il s'agit une fois
encore d'un transfert de charge de
l'État vers les collectivités sans
compensation la question financière
n'est pas de très loin le problème
principal le plus important et le
transfert de responsabilité et cet
étrange vision du suivi d'un enfant où
ce n'est plus ni lui ni ses besoins qui
sont au cœur de cet accompagnement mais
le temps sur lequel il est exercé
scolaire ou périscolaire monsieur le
ministre probablement faudra-t-il revoir
en profondeur la politique d'inclusion
des enfants est adolescent en situation
de handicap dont le nombre a plus que
quadruplé en 20 ans pour atteindre 430
000 enfants à cette rentrée soit environ
trois et demi pour cent des effectifs
totaux un élève en moyenne par classe
monsieur le ministre êtes-vous prêt à
vous engager pour mettre en place des
conventions de mise à disposition
d'aesh sur le temps de midi signé entre
votre ministère et les mers ce qui
favoriserait le recrutement et leur
formation et permettrait un suivi de
qualité des enfants concernés le Conseil
d'État recommande cette solution la loi
la permet les maires de France la
réclament Jean-Michel Blanquer l'avait
promise pourtant votre administration
refuse de la mettre en place
de fait de fait depuis la rentrée des
enfants ne sont pas accompagnés les
familles sont inquiète les équipes
éducatives sont déstabilisées monsieur
le ministre le plus grand des handicaps
c'est d'être absent là où notre présence
est utile
pour vous répondre la parole de
communiste de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse baby
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Cédric Vial vous avez raison
l'école inclusive est une des grandes
réussites du système scolaire avec
l'inclusion de plus de 430 000 élèves en
situation de handicap dans le milieu
scolaire ordinaire depuis 2005 une
croissance de plus de 25% depuis 2017
pour les accueillir nous avons notamment
recruté un grand nombre d'Ash ils sont
au nombre de 130 000 cette année avec un
rythme de recrutement de 4000 par an
4000 l'année prochaine si toutefois vous
approuvez le PLF 2023 nous avons des
difficultés en la matière y compris liés
au fait que les notifications parlaient
MDPH peuvent survenir très tard jusqu'à
la dernière minute avant la rentrée et
nous devons donc en quelque peu importe
courir derrière une marée de
notification qui crée des difficultés
pour les familles et pour les élèves je
le reconnais volontiers vous faites
allusion à une question particulière qui
est celle de la pose méridienne et vous
avez raison de mentionner l'arrêt du
Conseil d'État du 20 novembre 2020 qui
nous en juin de rémunérer les aesh sur
le temps scolaire et non pas sur le
temps périscolaire et donc nous devons
trouver la solution et la solution est
complexe d'un point de vue juridique
pour assurer la continuité cette
solution est étudiée par les services et
ça n'est pas mauvaise volonté de notre
part nous reconnaissons évidemment
l'intérêt qu'il y a à maintenir la
continuité particulièrement pour
certains types de handicap je pense ici
aux enfants en situation
autistiques 11% du total qui ont besoin
de continuité donc ce à quoi je m'engage
monsieur
sénateur c'est en collaboration avec les
collectivités les services juridiques
concernés à trouver la solution adéquate
nous sommes sur le point d'y arriver de
manière à assurer la meilleure solution
pour les enfants en situation de
handicap
merci je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Daphné rachmadou pour le groupe
de l'Union centriste lever la parole se
connaître
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des Transports
monsieur le ministre la France connaît
aujourd'hui des grèves parmi les
grévistes figurent les aiguillières du
rail ce déo de France aujourd'hui mais
ce d'Occitanie les ont précédés au
printemps leur doléances est simple il
réclame des embauches parce que notre
système est totalement obsolète il faut
encore des personnes physiques pour
assurer l'aiguillages des trains sur ce
sujet de modernisation du rail nous
avons 40 ans de retard
moderniser notre rail c'est mettre en
place de nouveaux systèmes de
signalisation à commencer par le système
européen de gestion du trafic
ferroviaire c'est aussi regrouper la
gestion des 2200 aiguillages dans 16
postes de commande centralisée du réseau
digitalisé
c'est enfin numériser le système de
gestion de transport pour combler cette
lacune un énorme effort d'investissement
doit être consenti aujourd'hui
c'est à dire au pire moment puisque
parallèlement la flambée du coude
l'électricité plombe les dépenses de
fonctionnement des autorités
organisatrices de transport à l'exemple
en Île-de-France ce surcourt représente
950 millions d'euros pour boucler le
budget 2023 l'essentiel de cette somme
n'étant pas financée le spectre
récemment agité d'un passe Navigo
augmenté à 100 euros inquiète je le dis
ici car je sais que nous partageons tous
ce point il n'est évidemment pas
question de pénaliser davantage les
usagers
dans ces conditions il est légitime de
craindre un effet de vaste communicant
entre des choix d'investissement et de
fonctionnement ce dernier phagocytan le
premier ce faisant c'est aussi une
remise en cause de notre chemin vers la
neutralité carbone car le report modal
sur le train est un axe clé de la
stratégie gouvernementale aussi Monsieur
le Ministre avez-vous identifié une
telle menace et comment comptez-vous y
répondre d'un point de vue budgétaire
monsieur Clément baume nous avait la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice rachmadou vous avez
raison de souligner ces deux points qui
sont extrêmement importants et que je
venais en moins bien distinguer même si
vous avez noté les effets de contagion
ou de vases communicants comme vous les
avez indiqué il y en a pas je veux
d'abord acheter là-dessus sur la
question du réseau nous avons rappelé
depuis la formation du gouvernement sur
l'autorité de la première mise
l'importance de notre investissement la
modernisation et la régénération du
réseau c'est en effet essentiel et il
est vrai que la France sur ce point
précis un réseau en moyenne plus vieux
que celui des grands pays européens qui
nous entourent et c'est la raison pour
laquelle depuis maintenant plusieurs
années nous portons un effort budgétaire
extrêmement important puisqu'il y a 5
ans nous étions à moins de 2 milliards
et demi d'investissement par an dans le
réseau ferroviaire dans le nouveau
contrat de performance nous sommes à 2,9
milliards d'euros par an sur 10 ans
faut-il accélérer faut-il aller plus
loin nous allons le regarder avec
notamment les niveau du comité
d'orientation des infrastructures mais
la priorité est très claire cela n'est
pas la même chose en effet que l'offre
de transport et que le fonctionnement
notamment affecté par les coûts
d'énergie dans certains cas parce que le
sujet est grave et parce que le sujet
est important nous devons être très
clair vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens sur
les responsabilités pour ne pas être
dans un jeu de posture qui est
responsable de l'organisation des
transports dans la région de France
comme dans les autres régions c'est Île
de France mobilité c'est la région
elle-même
est-ce que la région a été soutenue par
l'État ces dernières années oui plus
qu'aucune autre en France c'était sans
doute légitime et normal plus de 2
milliards d'euros de subventions et
d'avance remboursables depuis le début
de la crise covid je ne le conteste pas
c'était indispensable mais cela doit
être rappelé car c'est un peu oublié
parfois dans le débat public de ces
derniers jours et donc le prix du Pass
Navigo pour être très concret ne dépend
pas de l'état je tiens à le rappeler
parce que il est un peu facile de nous
dire que c'est nous qui le fixons
peut-être que ce serait mieux au moins
bien fait je n'en sais rien mais ça
n'est pas nous donc chacun doit
s'assumer ses responsabilités une fois
qu'on a dit cela je l'ai dit la prison
de Pécresse je ne jouerai aucun jeu de
renvoi de responsabilité c'est une
responsabilité commune que de faire
fonctionner dans les semaines qui
viennent dans les mois qui viennent pour
les Jeux Olympiques et Paralympiques et
bien au-delà nos réseaux franciliens
nous auront un contrat de plan état
région d'investirons les tâchera encore
au rendez-vous dans la clarté merci nous
en avons terminé avec les questions
gouvernement nos prochaines questions
auront lieu le mercredi 19 octobre
je vais suspendre la séance sera reprise
à 16h30 pour la suite du projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour la séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez suivi en direct et en intégralité
depuis 15h sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
parmi les moments forts de cette semaine
on retient cet échange entre le chef de
fil et des social des socialistes
Patrick Kanner et la première ministre
puisque effectivement les socialistes
ont voulu poser une question sur le
climat social actuel la gauche qui
réclame une hausse générale des salaires
face à la hausse des prix une
proposition que les spécialistes ont
fait à l'exécutif dès le mois de juillet
écoutez donc le chef de fil du PS au
Sénat
les pompes à essence ça sèche le pouvoir
d'achat est siphonné par l'inflation
mais les dividendes eux continuent à
ruisseler madame la Première ministre
cette situation est absurde certaines
entreprises peuvent tripler leur
bénéfices profitant de la crise actuelle
mais sans augmenter leurs salariés mais
sans contribuer à l'effort national ma
question est donc simple face à cette
aberration allez-vous choisir le camp de
la résignation
ou le camp du combat pour la justice
sociale c'est donc la première ministre
qui a répondu elle a tenu à vanter son
bilan expliquant par exemple que le SMIC
a été revalorisé en 2022 de 8% ce qui
est plus que l'inflation qu'elle est de
6% a-t-elle dit elle a salué les plus de
500 accords de branche déjà signé depuis
le début de l'année 2022 écoutez la
suite Elizabeth
je sais que vous le savez c'est du
dialogue social que viendra la réponse
le dialogue social j'y crois
profondément mais le dialogue social
c'est se mettre autour de la table c'est
respecté les accords majoritaires c'est
chercher des compromis ça n'est pas
bloqué le pays alors oui mon
gouvernement croit au dialogue social
nous prenons nos responsabilités pour
que ce dialogue social puisse se tenir
et que les résultats en soi respectés
voilà pour l'un des temps forts de cette
séance et à mon avis que c'était la
toute première question dès 15h il y en
a eu d'autres comme ça autour des prix
du carburant et également autour des
prix et des hausses de l'énergie on voit
un savent comme ça a été au cœur des
préoccupations des sénateurs cette
semaine Tam
merci merci Quentin pour toutes ces
explications on va vous retrouver bien
sûr tout au long de ce débrief se
débrief pour lequel j'ai le plaisir
d'accueil à Martin lévrier bonjour vous
êtes sénateur renaissance des Yvelines
vice-président de la commission des
affaires sociales face à vous à Hermann
bonjour bonjour C'est natrice communiste
de la Loire et vice-présidente de la
Commission des lois et j'ai enfin un
plaisir d'accueillir Françoise Gatel
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous c'est
une actrice Union centriste
d'Ille-et-Vilaine et présidente de la
délégation aux collectivités alors
Quentin on a parlé à l'instant à la
crise la pénurie de carburant bien sûr
et dans tous les esprits Françoise Gatel
est-ce que le gouvernement a eu raison
d'annoncer ses réquisitions hier
d'Elizabeth borne encore une nouvelle
réquisition possible annoncée par
Olivier Vérand tout à l'heure est-ce
qu'une face est-ce que c'est une façon
et bien de mettre la pression de façon
saine ou bien de mettre de l'huile sur
le feu
alors je sais pas si on met de l'huile
sur le fait en tout cas moi je pense à
tous les gens qu'on croise quand on va
remplir notre réservoir et ça devient
très compliqué pour des tas de gens qui
ont besoin d'aller travailler ou pour ou
pour des infirmières ou des médecins
deuxièmement je pense qu'il faut quand
même pas oublier comment se gonfler est
née c'est à dire avant l'ouverture de
négociation il y a un bras de fer qui
est entamé d'une manière que je trouve
tout à fait en décalage avec une
attitude de négociation qui est une
demande des salariés j'entends mais on
ne commence pas à les négocier en
mettant un fusil sur l'attente à son
interlocuteur et d'autre part en prenant
le pays en otage donc je pense que le
gouvernement doit prendre la mesure de
la situation les syndicats aussi on doit
retrouver la raison et que s'il faut
réquisitionner il faut le faire car on
ne peut pas avoir un pays à sec parce
qu'on bloque je vous prie de m'excuser
je vous interrompre c'est le principe de
cette émission mais on fait aussi les
réactions celle la différence on va
rejoindre tout de suite Alexandre
Poussard qui se retrouve avec Roland
Lescure justement d'ailleurs pour parler
de ce sujet effectivement Roland Lescure
cette première réquisition d'un centre
de dépôt de carburant est-ce que ça va
pas jeter de l'huile sur le feu dans les
négociations entre syndicats et
direction de Total et des sceaux c'est
pas moi qui l'ai dit c'est Maurice
Thorez un moment faut savoir arrêter une
grève il y a eu du dialogue ancien
dirigeant communiste oui il y a eu du
dialogue social il y a eu des
négociations il y a eu un accord en tout
cas pour ce qui est raffineries des
sauts à l'accord majoritaire par
ailleurs il est logique que les gens
reprennent le travail après la signature
d'un arrêt majoritaire n'en déplaise à
deux syndicats qui aujourd'hui sont
minoritaires donc le gouvernement
d'abord fait sa part du travail prend sa
part de responsabilité et surtout en
temps en cela je pense l'immense
majorité des Français des Français qui
considèrent certes que le dialogue
social c'est bien mais que ça doit pas
se transformer en blocage antisocial pas
de blocage en tout cas du côté de la
droite on est assez critique aussi sur
la réaction du gouvernement qui est jugé
trop tardive insuffisante pour l'instant
c'est juste un centre de dépôt qui est
réquisitionné et est-ce que ça va
vraiment et bien soulager le blocage
actuel qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ces
critiques on répond qu'on a laissé le
dialogue social se faire et que si ça
n'avait pas été le cas on ne l'aurait
peut-être aussi reproché donc c'est vrai
qu'il faut trouver un équilibre laissez
le temps au temps on est dans une
période difficile où les négociations
salariales sont finalement nécessaires
un peu partout pas seulement dans les
raffineries elles ont besoin de se tenir
après il faut que chacun prenne ses
restes responsabilités les oppositions
le gouvernement la majorité et les
syndicats y compris ce minoritaires ça
c'est important je pense est-ce que vous
pourrez aller sur d'autres réquisitions
pour vraiment soulager ce blocage des
stations services il est évident qu'on
suit la situation j'allais dire heure
par heure et qu'on adaptera la réponse
du gouvernement au comportement des uns
des autres et qu'on fera tout pour que
les Français et les Français aient accès
à adolescence pour aller travailler pour
aller soigner pour vivre tout simplement
dernière question sur le sujet que vous
avez évoqué durant cette séance cet
après-midi les entreprises notre
industrie face à la crise de l'énergie
avec certaines une entreprise qui sont
obligées de fermer de mettre la clé sous
la porte temporairement car elles ne
peuvent pas payer leurs factures
d'énergie et ce qu'il y a un soutien
financier de l'État sur ces entreprises
qui sont obligées de fermer bien sûr ça
fait 5 ans qu'on réindustrialise la
France on va pas laisser la crise en
Ukraine nous des industrialisés donc on
soutient les entreprises françaises et
surtout on augmente le soutien on le
rend plus souple flexible on le prolonge
tout ça se fait dans le cas de
négociation européenne qui sont
extrêmement ambitieuses qui vont je
pense déboucher comme toujours en Europe
à minuit moins 5 à la dernière minute
dans les jours qui viennent il y a un
sommaire européen les 20 et 21 octobre
prochain on travaille fort pour que
d'ici là on puisse soulager nos
entreprises il est hors de question que
l'entreprise l'industrie française soit
la victime collatérale du conflit en
Ukraine merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu
aux questions depuis que c'est NON MERCI
MERCI BEAUCOUP Alexandre voilà on va
également parler sur ce plateau et de la
crise des carburants et de la crise de
l'énergie mais d'abord et bien on
revient tout de suite vers vous car vous
êtes également avec le ministre en
charge des relations avec le Parlement
Franck Riester c'est à VOUS Alexandre
avec une première question sur un fait
d'actualité qu'on vient d'apprendre
monsieur le ministre l'Assemblée
nationale vient de rejeter un article du
budget sur le déficit un rejet d'emblée
est-ce que ça pourrait accélérer une
procédure de 49-3 oui c'est un article
dit liminaire donc au début de la
discussion du projet loi de finances un
peu d'ailleurs comme les articles qui
hier qui ont été discutés dans le cadre
de la loi de programmation qui a vu
finalement les oppositions qui n'ont
quasiment rien en commun ou simplement
de s'opposer sur des perspectives de
bonnes gestion de l'argent public ou de
maîtrise de la dette ou de maintien des
engagements et de tenues des engagements
de la France vis-à-vis de l'Europe
notamment et c'est ce qui s'est passé
tout à l'heure en propos liminaire
j'espère que en article liniens j'espère
que ça ne sera pas la façon dont on te
les débats vont se tenir à partir de
maintenant à l'Assemblée nationale parce
que nous voulons avoir du temps au débat
nous voulons laisser les députés de la
majorité mais aussi de l'opposition les
plus constructives possible essayer
d'améliorer le texte participer au débat
qu'attendent les Français quand il
s'agit du budget de l'État si c'était
pas le cas à ce moment-là nous prenions
on aurait responsabilités mais on n'est
pas du tout dans cet état d'esprit et
nous voulons simplement que le moment
venu
l'État et la France donc se dotent d'un
budget et nous serons amenés
éventuellement à ce moment-là à utiliser
le 49-3 mais alors est-ce qu'on peut
débattre d'un budget alors que le
déficit de ce budget a été rejeté par
l'Assemblée nationale oui puisque c'est
des perspectives c'est des c'est ce sont
des perspectives mais pour autant c'est
un signal que les oppositions de la
France insoumise en passant par le
rassemblement national des LR au
socialistes s'unissent votre ensemble
pour dire non on veut pas de maîtrise de
la dette ou on ne veut pas de finances
de se dire un cadre au budget
d'aujourd'hui de demain donc il y a déjà
une stratégie de blocage des oppositions
selon vous non non je ne dis je ne dis
pas ça et c'est un article luminaire un
peu symbolique
qu'ils ont souhaité voté ensemble je
suis pas sûr que le symbole soit le
meilleur possible en tout état de cause
nous on reste dans notre méthode notre
état d'esprit que de travailler en bonne
intelligence avec les oppositions et la
majorité les oppositions constructives
et la majorité alors on le rappelle
aujourd'hui le Conseil des ministres à
autorisé le gouvernement à utiliser
l'article 49-3 de la Constitution pour
et bien possiblement passer en force sur
ces textes budgétaires sans tenir compte
du vote des député est-ce que c'est déjà
un aveu de faiblesse du gouvernement
c'est-à-dire que vous n'aurez pas de
majorité sur ces bulances c'est pas un
passage en France c'est un disposition
qui existe dans la Constitution donc
c'est tout à fait légal ça existe et ça
me permet simplement de se doter d'un
budget à partir du moment où les
oppositions depuis le départ depuis
longtemps maintenant annoncé que quoi
qu'il arrive votre est contre le budget
pour autant on estime que c'est
important à la fois pour les députés de
l'opposition constructive de pouvoir
s'exprimer sur les différents articles
du budget mais aussi les député de la
majorité qui veulent améliorer avec
bonne foi avec leur expérience leur
regard le texte que propose le
gouvernement je crois beaucoup au
travail parlementaire de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat j'ai été discuter
pendant 12 ans je sais l'importance du
travail parlementaire donc de nous du
temps pour travailler si le débat est
constructif s'il y a pas d'obstruction
et le moment venu nous prenons nos
responsabilités pour doter de la France
d'un budget ça ça sera le à la fin du
but du débat et combien de jours vous
donnez pour avant d'utiliser ce 49 3 à
la fin du débat quand le débat aura été
à son terme et à condition bien
évidemment je le répète que le débat
soit à la hauteur de ce qu'attendent les
Français et de nous je pense la
représentation nationale merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à mes questions merci
merci beaucoup beaucoup Alexandre pour
cette nouvelle interview et puis avant
et bien de commencer notre débat sur les
carburants on va conclure avec et bien
c'est lui qui a ouvert cette séance de
questions au gouvernement à votre micro
Patrick canner le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat qui interpellé la
première ministre tout à l'heure et bien
sur la crise sociale actuelle mais oui
il interpellation de Patrick canard
notamment sur les inégalités salariales
qui sont accrues du fait notamment de
l'inflation est-ce que la réponse de la
première liste vous a satisfait
notamment sur les négociations entre les
branches qui avancent selon elles et
pourront permettre une hausse des
salaires dans les dans chaque branche
nous on est vraiment en totale des
accords moi ce que j'attends du
gouvernement c'est qu'il fixe le cap y
compris par une hausse significative du
SMIC et engagé une conférence salariale
permettant une négociation non pas par
branche les sans penser que la
responsabilité serait-elle que chacun
trouverait un accord on voit bien au
niveau de Total et les enneigenticiens
en général ça ne marche pas donc je
pense que le gouvernement aujourd'hui se
trompe très simplement et que la colère
gronde quand vous avez un patron
monsieur punaise pour Yannick pour ne
pas le citer qui augmente de 52% en 2021
pour un salaire mensuel mensuel de
500000 euros et que vous avez en face
des salariés qu'est-ce qu'il demande 10
% l'augmentation 7 % pour l'inflation 3
% pour l'enrichissement d'entreprise ben
voilà il y a quelque chose qui ne tourne
pas et je n'ai pas satisfait de la
réponse de la première ministre ça veut
dire que ça veut dire que vous approuvez
à la reconduite de la grève sur cette
pénurie de carburant je suis un peu il y
a les syndicats je n'ai pas me prononcer
sur l'opportunité de cette rencontre
c'est au syndicat de de le décider ce
que je sais c'est qu'aujourd'hui notre
pays est bloqué que le désordre
s'installe et que le gouvernement porte
une part de responsabilité dans le fait
de ne pas avoir engagé une grande
négociation salariale au niveau du
territoire du niveau du pays et
qu'aujourd'hui on en a les conséquences
en tout cas la première industrie
Elisabeth borne l'art après l'a rappelé
il y aura bien des contributions des
taxes sur les super profils notamment
sur les profits des groupes donc vous
êtes plutôt satisfait sur ce point non
et non ça va pas loin non parce que vous
voyez ça va ramener 200 220 millions
d'euros dans le budget alors que nous
avons une proposition qui est claire sur
les plus grandes entreprises vous prenez
par exemple la CMA CGM contre
l'entreprise qui fait des containers
enfin qui fait du transport maritime ils
ont augmenté leur profit de 250 % en un
semestre écoutez ça ne marche pas donc
nous ce que nous proposons c'est certes
une contribution exceptionnelle mais qui
ramènerait entre 15 et 20 milliards
d'euros voilà 200 millions d'euros d'un
côté 15 et 20 milliards d'euros de
l'autre chercher l'erreur alors sur
cette question de l'inflation il y aura
dimanche prochain une marge contre la
vie chère notamment à laquelle
participera Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-ce
que vous défilerez Patrick canard à
titre personnel non je l'ai déjà exprimé
y compris ce matin sur une autre chaîne
je considère que les partis politiques
doivent accompagner ou en syndical y
compris dans les manifestations je les
fais de nombreuses reprises dans ma vie
politique mais pas en première ligne et
je pense que voilà sur un sujet comme
cela c'est d'abord les syndicats qui
doivent porter la parole et les
politique ont d'autres lieux pour le
faire et en particulier le Parlement
donc pas d'union entre les politiques et
les syndicats en tout cas il y a la
Charte d'Amiens depuis 1920 qui précise
que chacun est à sa place merci beaucoup
Patrick canard d'être venu au micro de
public c'est NON MERCI MERCI BEAUCOUP
Alexandre pour toutes ces réactions on
va reprendre notre débat toujours qui
est sur ce même climat social et sur la
question bien sûr de la pénurie de
carburant qu'est-ce que vous vous pensez
c'est celui qui Herman et bien de la
position caprice le gouvernement
aujourd'hui celle et bien des
réquisitions d'un entrepôt hier et
peut-être d'un nouvel entrepôt je crois
que tout d'abord c'est une vraie
question à laquelle sont confrontées nos
concitoyens depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines y compris un choix politique
tarifaire notamment de Total qui a fait
que avant même d'ailleurs la grève des
salariés un certain nombre de stations
Total ont connu des pénuries pendant
quelques jours parce qu'il y a eu une
course y compris dans les mesures qui
ont été votées d'aide et de chaque qui
ont été donnés à total de la part de
l'État pour faire baisser le esprit
d'essence et que nous payons finalement
aujourd'hui une politique qui depuis
malheureusement plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois n'est pas à la hauteur du
besoin les salariés de Total et ça vient
d'être rappelé ça vient d'être rappelé
ce sont mis en grève tout d'abord ils se
mettent en grève parce que oui il y a
quand même un scandale que je crois
personne ne peut aider la réalité qui
est que dans une entreprise où le chef
d'entreprise puisse s'augmenter de 52%
ne rien vouloir entendre sur les
conditions de travail des salariés sur
le prix de l'essence vendu à la pompe et
dont chacun aujourd'hui c'est ce que
cela signifie et de toujours se réfugier
derrière des aides de l'État un moment
donné oui un stop il faut que ça
s'arrête sur la situation du
gouvernement mais je crois que vous
savez en politique on peut disserter les
faits par le même depuis que Madame
Elisabeth borne a annoncé la réquisition
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis hier il
y a plus de sites qui sont en grève il y
a des organisations syndicales qui nous
rejoint le mouvement de grève et la
question des blocages donc ce n'est pas
la bonne réponse mais ça depuis Nicolas
Sarkozy pourtant cela se sait ce n'est
pas la bonne réponse y compris il va
avoir des procédures judiciaires et elle
risque en plus de donner raison aux
salariés la vraie réponse le
gouvernement la vraie réponse puisque
j'ai entendu ce qu'elle dit Madame j'ai
compris entendu jusqu'à dit Monsieur
Véran à la réponse de mon collègue Eric
beau qu'est-ce qu'ils sont tant attachés
au dialogue social aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus de dialogue social dans les grands
groupes de la pétrochimie qu'il
réunissent sous l'autorité du
gouvernement les chefs d'entreprise les
organisations dans leur diversité plutôt
que de chercher à les opposer par des
jeux habiles certes que la loi el khomri
leur permet mais de qui représente quoi
qu'il réunissent sous leur régime sous
leur autorité et que l'on remette à plat
à la question des profits et des supers
profits qui ont été soutenus par
certains groupes ici au Sénat mais qui
n'ont pas été adopté qu'il remettent à
plat la Condy une condition de travail
et le prix à la pompe pour tout un
chacun et pas simplement des
réquisitions qui vont certes permettre
aux professions prioritaires de la
Renaissance mais qui ne règleront pas le
quotidien des Françaises et des Français
demain ça on en a tous conscience
surtout que pour l'instant on parle de
la réquisition seulement de 1 ou 2
entrepôts
Martin lévrier quel est le quel est le
rôle du gouvernement est-ce que est-ce
qu'avec ce réquisition il a mis l'huile
sur le feu est-ce qu'il a envoyé un
signal politique qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
quel est le rôle du gouvernement dans
une économie qui n'est pas administrée
parce que j'entends ma collègue par
Little j'avais le sentiment qu'elle
rêvait et je crois qu'elle en rêve d'une
économie administrée mais ça n'est pas
le cas et l'espace on serait pas acquis
par deux Français
voilà mais nous sommes en économie dites
libérale dans une économie où le marché
fonctionne et une là nous parlons de
deux entreprises pour le moment total
d'un côté et exondre de l'autre une
Française et l'autre qui ne l'est pas
nous avons un deux expériences
différentes au même moment la première
chez Total des négociations annuelles
des salaires qui devaient commencer en
tout début d'année prochaine je crois ou
fin de cette année qui se devrait être
avancé parce que le gouvernement a
fortement assisté aussi et c'est là où
il peut avoir un rôle de dire écouté de
discussions et d'explications et de
négociations
on verra à la fin mais c'est je crois
que le rôle du gouvernement a été
excellent là en disant écoutez s'il vous
plaît on sent que vous mettez à mal
la vie équilibrée du pays vous vous
gênez énormément de des millions de
personnes qui ont besoin de leur voiture
et qui gagnent des salaires qui n'ont
rien à voir avec